i'll tell you sort of my
own personal experience and i think it's
one that people share
i've experienced this with two people i
ran to nietzsche
but when i brought up iran when i was in
my early 20s
the number of eye rolls i got from
sort of you know like advisors and so on
that of dismissal i've seen that
later in life about more more specific
concepts in artificial intelligence and
technical where
people decide that this is this is a set
of ideas that are acceptable
and these sets of ideas are not and they
dismissed iran
without giving me any justification of
why they dismissed her except
oh that's something you're into when
you're
19 or 20. that's same thing people say
about nietzsche well that's just
something you do when you're
in college and you take an intro to
philosophy course
so and i've never really heard anybody
cleanly articulate
their opposition to iran in my own
private little circles and so on
maybe one question i just want to ask is
why is there such a opposition guy rand
and maybe another way to ask the same
thing is what's
misunderstood about iran so
we haven't talked about the philosophy
so it's harder to answer right now we
can return to it if you think that's the
right way to go
well let me let me give a broad answer
and then and then and then we'll do the
philosophy and then we'll return to it
because i think it's important to know
something about her ideas she
i think her philosophy challenges
everything it it really does it shakes
up the world
it challenges so many of our
preconceptions
it challenges so many of the things that
people take
for granted as truth from
religion to morality to to politics to
almost everything there's never quite
been a thinker like her
in the sense of really challenging
everything and doing it systematically
and
having a complete philosophy that is a
challenge to everything that has come
before her now i'm not saying
they're on threads that connect they are
right in politics there might be a
threat and
immorality there might be but on
everything there's just never been
like it and people are afraid
of that because it challenges them to
the course she's basically telling you
to rethink
almost everything um and that is
that that people reject the other thing
that it does
and this goes to this point about oh
yeah that's what you do when you're
14 15 right yeah she points out to them
that they've lost
something they've lost their idealism
they've lost a youthful idealism
what is what makes youthfulness
meaningful other than you know we're in
better physical shape
yeah starting to feel because i'm
getting older
yeah when we're young we you know
sometime in the teen years right there's
something that happens to human
consciousness
we almost awaken anew right we
we suddenly discover that we can think
of ourselves we suddenly discover
that not everything our parents and our
teachers tell us is true
we suddenly discover that this tool our
minds is suddenly available to us
to discover the world and to discover
truth
and it is a time of idealism it's a time
of
whoa i want to you know the better
teenagers i want to know about the world
i want to go out there i don't believe
my parents i don't believe my teachers
and this is healthy
this is fantastic and i want to go out
there and experiment and that gets us
into trouble right we do stupid things
when we're teenagers
why because we're experimenting it's the
experiential part of it right we want to
go and experience
life but we're learning it's part of the
learning process and
and and we become risk takers because we
want to experience
but the risk is something we need to
learn because we need to learn where the
boundaries are
and one of the damages that helicopter
parents do is they prevent us from
taking those risks so we don't learn
about the world and we don't learn
about where the boundaries are so the
teenage years are these years of wonder
they're depressing when you're in them
for a variety of reasons which i think
primarily have to do with the culture
but also
with oneself but they are exciting that
periods of discovery and
people get excited about ideas and good
ideas bad ideas all kinds of ideas
and then what happens we settle
we compromise whether that happens in
college
where we're taught that nothing exists
and nothing matters and start being
bni let's be a cynics b whatever or
whether it happens when we get married
and get a job and have kids and they're
too busy and can't think about ideals
and forget and get just get into the
norm of
conventional life or whether it's
because a mother pester us
uh pesters us to get married and have
kids and do all the things that she
wanted us to do
we give up on those ideals and
there's a sense in which ein rand
reminds them
that they gave up that's beautifully
that's so beautifully put and so true
yeah it's
it's worth pausing on that uh
this dismissal people forget
the the beauty of that curiosity that's
true in the scientific field too
is uh i mean
that youthful joy of like everything is
possible
and we can understand it with the tools
of our mind
yes and that's what it's all about
that's what iran's ideas at the end of
the day all boil down to it's that
confidence and that
passion and that curiosity and that
interest
and if you you know think about what
academia does to so many of us right
we go into academia and and we're
excited about we're going to learn stuff
we're going to discover things and then
they stick you into sub subfield and
examining some minutia that's
insignificant and unimportant
and and to get published you have to be
conventional you have to do what
everybody else does and then there's the
10-year process of seven years where
they
put you through this torture to write
papers that fit into a certain mold
and by the time you're done you're in
your mid-30s and you've done nothing you
discovered nothing you you're all in
this minutia
in this stuff and it's destructive in
where's holding on to that passion
holding on to that knowledge and that
confidence
is hard and when people do away with it
they become cynical
yeah and they become part of the system
and they inflict the same pain
on the next guy that they suffered
because that's part of how it works
yeah there's uh this happens in
artificial intelligence this happens
when like
a young person shows up and with like
fire in their eyes and they say
i want to understand the nature of
intelligence
and everybody rolls their eyes
well for these same reasons because they
spent so many years on the very
specific set of questions that um
that kind of they compete over and they
did write papers over and have
conferences about
and it's true those that incremental
research is the way you make progress
answering the question of what is
intelligence exceptionally difficult
but when you mock it you actually
destroy the realities when
when we look like centuries from now we
look back at this time
for this particular field of artificial
intelligence
it would be the people who will be
remembered will be the people who've
asked the question
and made it their life journey of what
is intelligence
and actually had the chance to succeed
most will fail asking that question but
the ones that like had a chance of
succeeding
and had that throughout their whole life
and i suppose the same is true for
philosophy it's in every field
it's it's it's asking the big questions
and staying curious and staying
passionate and staying excited
and accepting failure right accepting
that you're not going to get it first
time you're not going to get the whole
thing
but and sometimes you have to do the
minutiae work and i'm not here to say
nobody should specialize you shouldn't
do the minute you have to do that
but there has to be a way to do that
work and keep the passion and keep
and keep it all integrated that's
another thing i mean we don't live in a
culture
that integrates right we live in a
culture that
is all that is all about you know this
minutia
and not and you know medicine is another
field where you you specialize in the
kidney i mean the kidneys connected to
other things you've gotta
and we don't have a holistic view of
these things and i'm sure in artificial
intelligence
you're not going to make the big leaps
forward without a holistic view
of what it is you're trying to achieve
and maybe that's the question what is
intelligence but
that's the kind of questions you have to
ask
to make big leaps forward to really move
the field in in a positive direction
and it's the people who can think that
way who move
fields they move technology you move
ever anything anything is
is everything is like which just like
you said is painful because
underlying that kind of questioning is
well maybe the work i've done for the
past 20 years
was uh was a dead end
and you have to kind of face that even
just it might not be true but even just
facing that reality
is it's just it's a it's a painful
feeling absolutely but
but it's that's part of the reason why
it's important to enjoy the work that
you do
right so that even if it doesn't
completely worked out issues
it was not a waste because you enjoyed
the process and if you learn
as as any entrepreneur knows this right
and if you learn
from the waste of time from the errors
from the mistakes
then you can build on them and make
things even better right and so the next
20 years a
a a massive success
you